[Musique]
un 100% Sénat qui est un 100% réforme
des retraites aujourd'hui soyez les
bienvenus qui est pour qui est contre le
recul de l'âge de départ à la retraite à
64 ans c'était la question qui était
posée hier au sénateur les élus ont
entamé l'examen de l'article 7 de la
réforme article très attendue puisqu'il
s'agit du coeur du projet de loi du
gouvernement et vous allez le voir tout
ne s'est pas passé comme prévu
monsieur Magnier
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement vise à ne pas décaler l'âge
légal de 62 64 ans et ne pas accéder ne
pas accélérer la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme Touraine la réforme proposée par
le gouvernement apparaît effectivement
injuste particulièrement parce que là je
l'égale de départ de la retraite serait
décalé et que le nombre d'années de
cotisations augmenterait plus vite que
prévu le sénateur socialiste vous le
disent ils sont profondément opposés à
cette réforme qui n'est ni plus ni moins
que le plus injuste des impôts sur la
vie notre système de retraite n'est pas
menacé à long terme il doit simplement
faire face aux conséquences momentanées
du papy boom dans les décennies 2030 à
2050 et d'autres choix sont possibles
ils ont été longuement exposés ici
depuis le début de nos débats
de plus en se conjuguant à la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui réduit la durée
de l'indemnisation et à celle du RSA
cette réforme va précariser les
travailleurs seniors qui voient leur
durée d'indemnisation chômage réduite de
8 mois et non donc plus que le RSA pour
vivre si bien sûr ici en droit qui peut
croire raisonnablement que ce que
propose le gouvernement dans sa réforme
est un quelconque qui est fait
amortisseur sur cette paupérisation en
marche des travailleurs seniors ce
projet de loi de régression sociale
apparaît inacceptable c'est une réforme
injuste
inutile et inefficacité donc ici de
supprimer l'article de ce projet
même la présidente Rossignol merci
monsieur le Président j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure l'Inter syndical
non pas que je veux absolument mettre sa
porte-parole dans cette hémicycle mais
pour connaître le mouvement social le
mouvement syndical depuis de nombreuses
années je sais mesurer ce que signifient
un mouvement syndical uni dans un moment
comme celui qu'on vit et je sais aussi
ce que signifie la mobilisation de 1
million 500 000 à 3 millions de
personnes contre une réforme
l'intersyndicale s'est réunit ce soir
elle a donné ses nouvelles
préconisations je vais vous les lire
je pense que c'est pas une intéressante
pour vous non plus même si vous les
soutenez pas c'est toujours bien de
savoir ce que font les autres le 16
février face à l'absence de réponse du
gouvernement l'Inter syndicale amené
appeler à mettre la France à l'arrêt
cette mars c'est une journée historique
par l'ampleur de ses gravés de ses
mobilisations à ce jour c'est
mobilisations énormes conduites par une
interne de syndicaturite unie non reçu
aucune réponse de la part du
gouvernement cela ne peut plus durer le
silence du président de la République
constitue un problème démocratique grave
qui conduit un manquablement à une
situation qui pourrait devenir explosive
en responsabilité l'intersyndicale cette
restera au président de la République
l'Inter syndicale appel à une nouvelle
mobilisation interprofessionnelle ce
samedi 11 mars puis la semaine prochaine
à une manifestation le jour de la
commission mix paritaire elle appelle la
population a continué à l'obligation et
les actions encore plus massivement pour
dire non à cette réforme injuste et
brutale
voyez-vous
cette intersey syndicale elle prend à la
fois la responsabilité de continuer
d'accompagner le mouvement social et
nous nous devons être à la hauteur de
cette responsabilité monsieur le
ministre vous ne pouvez pas continuer de
ne pas répondre au mouvement social et à
l'intersyndical et nous chers collègues
en votant nos amendements de suppression
de l'article 7 nous permettrions à tout
le monde de sortir la tête haute de
cette affaire madame la Présidente
oui merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues mesdames Messieurs
les messieurs encore les membres du
gouvernement je crois qu'il n'y a aucune
mais vraiment strictement aucune donnée
chiffrée qui ne permet de justifier que
l'allongement de l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans ainsi que
l'allongement des trimestres de
cotisation et nécessaire nous en avons
déjà fait la démonstration lors de nos
précédents débats je crois que nous
sommes assez offensif et nous
continuerons donc à dire et à proposer
que des économies et enfin à dire que
des économies peuvent être réalisés
ailleurs sans porter atteinte au régime
actuel de retraite selon l'institut
national d'étude démographique
l'espérance de vie doit aussi être
appréciée en tenant compte de l'âge
auquel il y a un vrai risque
d'incapacité dans les gestes de la vie
quotidienne ce concept rejoint en
quelque sorte celui de l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé que nous défendons et
bien chers collègues cette espérance de
vie prenant en compte l'incapacité à
effectuer les gestes de la vie
quotidienne se situent en France à
64,1 an pour les femmes et
62,7 ans pour les hommes la réforme donc
actuelle qui nous est proposée par le
gouvernement avec la complicité de la
droite sénatoriale aggrave le risque de
liquider les pensions de retraite à un
âge où le retraité n'est plus ou la
retraité mais plus en mesure de profiter
comme il ou elle le souhaiterait du
fruit de son labeur nous maintenons donc
que votre projet celui de la destruction
sociale et après ce que ce qui vient
d'être vient d'être dit par Madame
Rossignol je le répète il faudrait
peut-être que vous entendiez à la fois
ce qui s'est dit exprimé aujourd'hui
dans les rues des villes et qu'elle soit
petite moyenne ou grande et que vous
écoutiez aussi et que vous sachiez lire
le communiqué le communiqué de la terre
syndicale
merci monsieur le Président avec cette
article 7 il s'agit en effet du recul de
l'âge de la retraite et de
l'accélération de la hausse des durées
de cotisation qui sont censées réduire
ou lutter contre les déficits de notre
système de protection sociale au passage
monsieur le ministre quand vous nous
dites tout à l'heure
que l'âge de départ sans décote sera
maintenu à 67 ans et ne sera pas à 69
ans j'espère que vous n'imaginez pas que
les Français vous remercient largement
parce que vous risquez d'être encore un
peu déçu au passage toujours je trouve
quand même assez inquiétant de constater
que
en fait la politique c'est
identifier des problèmes et il apporter
des réponses et si certains d'entre vous
sont assis à la droite de cette
hémicycle d'autres à la gauche de cette
hémicycle c'est que nous avons des
options différentes pour répondre à des
problématiques que nous pouvons parfois
identifier ensemble or je vois que
beaucoup ici
préféreraient un passage en force qu'un
débat sur des solutions alternatives à
ce report de l'âge de la retraite et les
Français le sentent bien qu'on leur
refuse ce débat c'est ça aussi qu'il
aimait de plus en plus nombreux dans la
rue parce que voilà un débat de société
au sens noble du terme qui pourrait
faire en sorte que nos concitoyens
renouent avec la politique mais vous la
refusez et encore une fois certains
d'entre vous préféreraient passer en
force et enfin puisqu'il s'agit de
prétendus déficit j'ai eu l'occasion
tout à l'heure de montrer en quoi le
coût social de ce report de l'âge allait
être très conséquent sur la vie
associative démocratique dans nos
communes etc je pense qu'il leur sera
aussi en termes de pure dépense sociale
par l'augmentation des arrêts de travail
par la baisse du niveau de pension qui
va faire en sorte que de nouvelles
dépenses sociales vont devoir être
déployées pour empêcher que des
retraités dont dans la pauvreté et donc
je crois qu'il n'est absolument pas
question d'économie avec ce projet
nous sommes en direct sur l'antenne de
Public Sénat la chaîne qui bouleverse
ces programmes pour suivre au plus près
l'examen de l'article 7 sur la mesure
d'âge de la réforme des retraites nous
arrivons dans les 10 dernières prises de
parole sur ces amendements de
suppression de l'article 7 retournant
l'émission le taux d'emploi des seniors
est de 35 %. donc allongez la durée
créera des retraités pauvres vous nous
dites c'est pas le sujet on vous a
proposé de financer autrement
t'accélérer riche non les dividendes
sûrement pas élargir l'assiette pas
possible gagner la bataille de l'emploi
attendez la loi travail l'égalité
salariale c'est la grande cause du
quinquennat vous allez voir taxer la
rente sûrement pas vous allez tuer le
ruissellement on vous a dit vous avez
une question démocratique vous êtes
minoritaire 3,5 millions de travailleurs
et de travailleuses dans la rue vous
avez assumé monsieur le ministre on
assume d'être impopulaire et donc pour
vous une seule solution deux ans de plus
deux ans qui vont peser sur les classes
populaires les essentiel très utile
celles et ceux qui ont tenu le pays à
bout de bras pendant le covid ceux qui
ont des cari arrachées les horaires
décalés ceux qui triment et que le
travail concasse le cœur et les esprits
mais vous vous nous parlez justice
travailler
alors que pour nous il faudrait partager
partager le travail le savoir et les
richesses enfin si vous n'êtes pas
convaincu un dernier
argument est-ce que vous pensez
sincèrement que c'est le moment même
Olivier Véran l'a dit
occupons-nous d'abord de l'inflation du
prix de l'électricité des salaires de
l'emploi de la formation et de la
réindustrialisation du pays avant de
voler les deux plus belles années des
retraites seul le ministre il est temps
de battre en retraite et de retirer
votre projet de loi
[Musique]
tu Laurent
oui merci monsieur le Président tout à
l'heure le président Retailleau nous a
dit quelque chose qui était faux
il nous a dit depuis 40 ans personne
n'est revenu sur une réforme des
retraites qui avait été votée c'est faux
en 1980 il y a 40 ans la gauche a voté
une réforme historique qui a passé l'âge
de départ à la retraite de 65 ans à 60
ans c'était une des réformes qui ont
marqué le siècle oui qui ont marqué un
siècle de progrès sociaux comme les
congés payés à une certaine époque comme
la réduction de la journée du temps de
travail à d'autres etc donc il y a eu un
progrès historique et la vérité c'est
qu'en fait vous ne l'avez jamais accepté
donc ensuite on a eu le droit à Balladur
en 93 à Fillon en 2003 et Sarkozy en
2010 et les 62 ans c'est déjà vous c'est
vous les 62 ans c'est vous qui avez
institué les 62 ans en 2010 et
aujourd'hui vous voulez passer à 64 ans
et si vous étiez resté au pouvoir si
vous étiez resté au pouvoir sans
discontinuer on discuterait pas 62 ou 64
on serait toujours restés à 65 et on
serait probablement à 67 aujourd'hui
parce que vous auriez rajouté deux ans
comme dodo dans d'autres pays européens
donc en vérité ce projet là c'est votre
projet depuis toujours et le et ce qu'on
a entendu de la part du rapporteur
Savary qui s'éclipse au moment où je
parle de lui c'est une fable c'est une
fable l'idée
l'idée
l'idée que vous êtes finalement obligé
d'en poser les 64 ans parce qu'on a fait
les 40 parce que toi Marisol Touraine a
fait les 43 nuts c'est de la blague en
vérité depuis 1980 votre rêve c'est de
revenir à 65 ans et aujourd'hui vous
progressez alors effectivement monsieur
Retailleau a raison
c'est une réforme de droite à laquelle
le gouvernement aujourd'hui sera lit
qu'il met en oeuvre que vous allez
soutenir cette réforme elle est à
contretemps elle est archaïque elle sera
combattue par une ne sera pas appliquée
madame linman
chers collègues républicains
vous jouez avec le feu
j'ai bien entendu l'argumentaire de
votre président de groupe monsieur
Retailleau
son argumentaire c'est
nous avons le courage de faire des
réformes un peu populaires
parce que nous savons mieux que le
peuple ce qui est bon pour la nation
alors on le fait une fois
et puis on le fait deux fois et puis on
croit qu'on va pouvoir continuer comme
ça
pendant des lustres pas figurez-vous que
non pour une raison simple c'est que la
première fois les Français ils peuvent y
croire vous allez sauver le système de
répartition vous allez répondre au
problème de du temps et les choses vont
être meilleures pour la nation
et puis il se rendent compte que réforme
après réforme c'est pire pour eux c'est
pire pour le pays donc il ne vous croit
plus
il ne vous croit plus et jamais dans
l'histoire le général de Gaulle aurait
eu comme raisonnement
oui oui
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
chaque fois
chaque fois que le général de Gaulle a
eu un doute
eu un doute sur le soutien des Français
il a été devant le peuple il a fait un
référendum vous vous avez peur de faire
cela
elle est conséquence de ces attitudes
elle est
conséquence de ses attitudes
accumuler dans le temps où vous
terrorisez que la bonne politique c'est
celle qui doit être faite contre le
peuple est la même le peuple à
s'abstenir elle amène le peuple à
accumuler la colère elle amène le peuple
à se démoraliser sur l'avenir de la
France elle amène le CUP vers l'extrême
droite merci Monsieur Ouzoulias
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre j'ai posé une
question et j'ai pas eu de réponse donc
vous vous me permettrez de reposer ma
question elle est très simple lors de la
campagne électorale le président de la
République avait expliqué que le recul
de l'âge de 2 ans permettrait de
financer un minimum retraite à 1200
euros pour tout le monde on sait
aujourd'hui que seul si si je peux je
peux vous redonner les propos de
Monsieur Macron on sait maintenant que
seul 10000 à 20000 retraités pourront en
bénéficier je vous repose donc une
nouvelle fois la question quel est le
gain budgétaire de cette réforme des
retraites les économistes évaluent à
0,6% du PIB le surcroît de recettes
budgétaire dans 10 ans est-ce que vous
nous confirmez maintenant cette
évaluation et je pense chers collègues
qu'il faudrait prendre conscience comme
l'a dit très bien le président
Retailleau qu'il s'agit aussi d'une
réforme budgétaire c'est un point c'est
très important que les Français sachent
que là on est en train de discuter d'un
nouvel impôt monsieur merci monsieur le
président
mes chers collègues commencez par ça
vous a pas échappé de temps en temps on
a eu des comparaisons
je vais vous parler de l'Allemagne pour
vous faire vibrer dans votre
enthousiasme le gouvernement et la
majorité sénatoriale un chiffre 20%
c'est le taux de pauvreté c'est le taux
de pauvreté des retraités en Allemagne
et puis allez c'est le même en Irlande
et pourtant l'âge de départ est à 66 ans
soit 10% de plus qu'en France
60% c'est le pourcentage de pays ayant
fait machine arrière après avoir
privatisé leur régime de retraite
diminution du taux de couverture baisse
des allocations de retraite aggravation
des inégalités de gens et de revenus
c'est-à-dire croyez la comparaison
européenne c'est charge la preuve
y compris par y compris des droites
libérales excusez-moi de le dire mais
par des droites libérales
la deuxième chose c'est que tout à
l'heure on a eu la confirmation d'autres
collègues l'ont affirmé mais là on a un
moment de clarification politique
le président Retailleau a été très clair
il a dit c'est une réforme de droite
donc nous sommes en train de discuter du
dréforme de droite et ça m'a fait penser
on a tous des loisirs etc j'ai pensé aux
formidable film le salaire de la peur
où il y a quatre aventuriers qui part
cupidité s'en vont à défier la nature là
on était dans les critères de pénalité
est-ce qu'on vient de vivre depuis jeudi
par le vote de la droite de la première
partie de la loi et par la défense de
rajouter deux années de plus vous êtes
en train de nous proposer de proposer
aux Français la retraite de la peur pour
les obliger à rentrer dans la
capitalisation voilà l'enjeu de cette
réforme merci Madame baraillasse
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre 70% des Français et plus de 90%
des salariés nous le savons sont opposés
à ce report de 62 à 64 ans de l'âge de
départ à la retraite le président de la
République avance qu'il faut que les
Français travaillent plus nous proposons
quand à nous qu'il travaille tous ce qui
permettrait d'abander les caisses des
assurances sociales avec les cotisations
nouvelles la dernière réforme
paramétrique des retraites qui fait
reculer l'âge de départ à la retraite de
60 à 62 ans évoqué par Pierre Laurent
tout à l'heure imposé par Nicolas
Sarkozy en 2010 a eu pour conséquence
selon l'inédith de plonger 100 000
seigneurs dans le chômage de longue
durée entre 2010 et 2022 il ne s'agit
pas on peut le dire d'une brillante
réussite imaginons un métallurgiste ou
un salarié à la chaîne chez Renault qui
travaille souvent en 3,8 continué à
occuper un poste de travail dans une
entreprise à 64 ans une infirmière me
disait récemment j'ai terminé ma
carrière émotionnel par un arrêt maladie
suite à un burn-out et une période de
chômage de deux ans comment une
infirmière une aide-soignante pourra
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans voire plus
repousser l'âge de départ à la retraite
c'est augmenter la période de non emploi
des seniors pour les seniors risquant de
ne pas toucher d'indemnités de chômage
durant ces années ils seront poussés
vers les minimas sociaux qui ne
permettent pas de vivre dignement est-ce
là la description d'une réforme de
gauche monsieur le ministre je ne crois
pas et si ce n'est pas l'indigeant index
seniors voté dans l'article 2 de votre
loi qui risque d'inciter les entreprises
à garder les plus de 60 ans dans leurs
effectifs l'allongement des carrières va
immanquablement provoquer un sur chômage
chez les salariés les plus âgés qui
risquent plus de ne pas avoir une
carrière complète ce qui aura un impact
négatif sur leur pension future faire
basculer les dépenses de retraite sur
les indemnités de chômage est une
politique qui n'a aucun sens d'un point
de vue économique pour toutes ces
raisons bien évidemment nous demandons
la suppression de
cette merci nous en avons terminé avec
les amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune je vais s'il vous
plaît je vais consulter la commission
avis de la commission
bien merci monsieur le Président
j'attendais effectivement
mon tour pour donner la vie de la
commission après tous ces amendements à
répétitifs
qui font pour certains tableaux de la
valeur travail particulièrement
apocalyptique il y a encore des gens
quand même qui je pense voit les choses
différemment
Monsieur Laurent Monsieur Laurent vous
avez dit que certains rêvaient un âge de
retraite à 64 ans mais un monsieur
Laurent moi la retraite à 60 ans pour
moi c'est un cauchemar ça veut dire
qu'on n'aime pas le système par
répartition ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas
vu la société la société vieillit
Monsieur Laurent il y a de moins en
moins de décence la longévité telle que
la retraite l'espérance de vie dure de
plus en plus longtemps et si vous voulez
prendre des mesures qui vont plomber le
système par répartition c'est que vous
n'aimez pas la répartition j'ai écouté
aussi monsieur Sueur monsieur Sueur qui
a fait une explication tout à fait
intéressante mais qui pense que en
travaillant effectivement plus sur la
durée et bien on pourrait peut-être
rendre les gens les plus heureux et bien
non on sait que plus la durée on
travaille sur la durée les 43 ans ça
fait les conséquences c'est qu'il y a
une diminution de la pension moyenne
calculée à de 300 euros lisez les tuques
d'impact je n'ai rien inventé donc ça
veut dire que vous n'aimez pas les
retraités que vous voulez faire des
retraités pauvres c'est la raison pour
laquelle je me tourne vers ce banc là de
l'hémicycle
ce banc là de l'émission pense qu'il
faut jouer sur le niveau de l'âge légal
mais chers collègues vous avez raison
vous avez raison parce que ces eux le
seul moyen dans un système pas
répartition de faire en sorte qu'on
arrive à élever le niveau des pensions
faire en sorte qu'on puisse dégager des
recettes supplémentaires et qu'on puisse
faire plus de solidarité mais vous
n'aimez pas la solidarité donc et nous
nous aimons la solidarité
et nous aimons la solidarité et nous
voudrions bien la proposer aux Français
non pas à travers des discours mais à
travers des actes ce sont les articles
suivants qui viennent pour les maires de
famille vous en parlez beaucoup nous
agissons
pour l'usure professionnelle
je vous ai taquiné pour l'usure
professionnelle nous avons des mesures
pour la retraite progressive nous avons
des mesures en conséquence il serait
temps monsieur le Président que nous
puissions passer dans l'examen du texte
les Français attendent de nous que l'on
donne un peu plus de justice sociale à
ce texte il en manque un peu messieurs
les ministres un peu plus de justice
sociale à travers les divers
dispositions que nous souhaiterions
vivement examinés voilà vous l'avez
compris mes chers collègues la vie sera
défavorable de la part de la Commission
la vie du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
en donnant la vie du gouvernement qui
sera défavorable en réponse aux 70
amendements de suppression je ne
reprendrai pas les arguments très
synthétiques qui ont été évoqués par
Olivier du soft mais je donnerais
quelques principes qui concernent la
fonction publique les agents de la
fonction publique qui sont effectivement
inclus dans cet article 7 et en le
faisant je veux me réjouir que
dans cette chambre on puisse débattre de
la situation des agents de la fonction
publique parce que cela n'avait pas été
possible à l'Assemblée nationale et je
pense que c'était dommage de ne pas
évoquer au fond les principes qui
concernent les agents de la fonction
publique et qui sont majoritairement
dans cet article 7 d'abord je le ferai
de façon monsieur le Président très
synthétique pour aller plus vite sur
ensuite explications sur les différents
amendements d'abord un principe d'équité
je crois que les Français n'auraient pas
compris que les mesures des efforts qui
concerne les salariés du privé ne soient
pas demander de façon absolument
symétrique aux agents de la fonction
publique ce sera le cas pour l'âge
d'ouverture des droits ce sera le cas
pour l'accélération de la durée de
cotisation ensuite un principe de
cohérence nous avons préservé et
conserver les caractéristiques
fondamentales du système de retraite
pour les agents de la fonction publique
sur le calcul sur les six derniers mois
calcule sur la rémunération indiciaire
des fonctionnaires ce que nous
conservons aussi c'est le principe des
catégories actives à tout point de vue
nous en conservons le principe mais nous
conservons aussi la durée de service
pour les catégories actives et Olivier
du stop l'a rappelé pour les catégories
actives comme pour les agences
sédentaires nous ne modifions pas l'âge
d'annulation de la décote c'est le cas
pour tous les agents de la fonction
publique et puis le troisième principe
c'est un principe de progrès parce que
en supprimant cet article 7 ce sont des
améliorations du système et des progrès
pour les fonctionnaires contre lequel
vous voteriez je veux mentionner de
façon très rapide 3 qui sont contenus
dans ce texte d'abord la portabilité des
droits pour les agents publics qui sont
dans les catégories actives la situation
actuelle c'est que si vous changez de
métier quand vous êtes policier que vous
devenez par exemple douanier ou agent de
la pénitentiaire vous perdez tout le
bénéfice de vos années passées en tant
que policier ou dans la fonction
publique pénitentiaire et bien grâce à
l'article 7 nous mettons fin à cette
situation injuste plus injuste encore
en votant contre l'article 7 vous
viendriez voter contre une mesure qui
est la suppression de la clause
d'achèvement la suppression de la clause
d'achèvement ça peut parfaite technique
quand on le dit comme ça mais c'est un
principe qui existe dans le système de
retraite actuel qui consiste à faire en
sorte que vous ne bénéficiez
des mesures qui concernent les
catégories actives seulement si vous
terminez votre carrière en tant que
catégorie actif c'est-à-dire dans le
métier pénible c'est à dire tout
l'inverse de ce que nous devons faire
pour aménager les fins de carrière et
bien dans cet article 7 on le votant
vous allez supprimer la clause
d'achèvement je citerai une troisième
amélioration elle concerne les
contractuels de la fonction publique 20%
des agents publics aujourd'hui les
contractuels qui aujourd'hui font
parfois le même métier que les agents
publics qui sont intégrés actives mais
qui ne bénéficient pas des mesures de
protection qui concernent les agents des
catégories actives et bien avec
l'article 7 vous feront vous ferez en
sorte que les agents contractuels dès
lors qu'ils seront titularisés dans la
fonction publique ils verront leurs
années passées en tant que contact
actuel parfois 5 ans parfois 6 ans je
pense au plus de 100 000 agents
contractuels qui sont des
aides-soignants à l'hôpital et bien vous
ferez en sorte que ces années passées
elles continueront et elles seront
intégrées dans les années de service
quand ils seront intitulés à réserves en
fonction publique voilà des avancées qui
sont inclus dans l'article 7 et autant
de bonnes raisons de donner un avis
défavorable aux amendements de
suppression de ce même article 7
du gouvernement avis défavorable de la
commission j'ai été saisi d'une demande
de scrutin public par la commission les
groupes communistes républications
écologie le groupe socialiste et le
groupe écologie solidarité et est
territoire je rappelle qu'il porte sur
les amendements identiques de
suppression d'explication de vote
monsieur dessus
oui merci monsieur le Président mais je
voudrais dire au rapporteur qui était
pas avec nous toute la nuit hier mais
que des amendements de solidarité on en
a posé un certain nombre qu'ils ont été
tous balayés mais oui nous aimons la
solidarité la vraie celle qui fait payer
ceux qui profitent le plus alors j'ai
déjà expliqué la la situation de blocage
démocratique dans laquelle nous étions
ce soir et et vous avez commencé ce
débat hier et avant-hier par refuser
tout autre mode de financement
alternatif avec logique du travail et
plus
pour les français pour les travailleurs
vous éloignez une fois de plus l'horizon
du répit avec cette réforme du décalage
de l'âge de départ à la retraite
l'horizon de la vie enfin sortie de la
course à la production pour nous
écologistes cette réforme va donc à
rebours de tous les enjeux du moment de
tous les enjeux du siècle et je veux
reprendre les propos de d'Olivier Véran
vous avez d'autres urgences à gérer nous
avons deux urgences à gérer le défi
climatique doit être la priorité absolue
qui devrait nous mobiliser qui
renouveliser ici soir et weekend s'il le
faut mais qui n'aurait ne mobilisé
beaucoup plus que cette réforme visant à
faire travailler toujours plus
travailler plus c'est produire plus
c'est extraire plus c'est polluer plus
faites pour servir un modèle économique
insatiable des structures du climat
cette réforme des retraites va un
rebours de l'urgence la vraie les
rapports du corps sont beaucoup moins
inquiétants que les rapports du GIEC
beaucoup moins précis sur l'avenir aussi
beaucoup moins implacable sur notre
destin commun si la retraite par
répartition doit être renforcée c'est
parce que c'est un système de solidarité
entre les générations et si nous devons
repenser nos modes de production et
notre rapport au travail c'est aussi
dans une logique intergénérationnelle de
protection des générations futures votre
réforme participe à une logique qui
épuise l'humain et la planète en visant
des objectifs insoutenables de
croissance fini dans un monde infini non
l'inverse dans une croissance infinie
dans un monde fini c'est pourquoi nous
sommes écologistes et nous refusons
votre logique obsolète et appelons à la
suppression de cet article monsieur
Breuillet
voilà nous avons eu 77 amendements de
suppression qui ont été présentés il y a
institut et la vie de la commission la
vie du gouvernement on passe maintenant
aux explications de vote chaque sénateur
dispose d'une explication de votre de 2
minutes et on voit que de nombreux
sénateurs de gauche s'inscrivent pour
ces explications
pour les femmes
c'est donc une réforme pour les
fonctionnaires
c'est donc une réforme pour les jeunes
c'est donc une réforme pour les ouvriers
pour les infirmières pour les
aides-soignants pour tous les métiers
pénibles mais ni les femmes ni les
fonctionnaires ni les jeunes ni les
infirmières ni les aides-soignants ni
tous ceux qui ont un métier pénible ne
la soutiennent quel ingratitude
quel ingratitude de ce peuple qui refuse
une réforme de progrès que vous nous
présentez et non seulement ils ne disent
pas seulement comme monsieur le
rapporteur avis défavorable ils disent
retrait
monsieur Retailleau
[Applaudissements]
c'est un rappel aux règlements monsieur
le Président à partir c'est sur la base
de l'article 38 77 amendements de
suppression
tout identique monsieur le Président je
demande cette application
donc je suis saisi par Monsieur
Retailleau président de groupe des
d'une
demande de clôture sur les explications
de vote sur les amendements numéro 3 à
2268 en application de l'article 38 de
notre règlement la clôture peut être
proposée lorsque au moins deux orateurs
c'est le cas d'avis contraire sont
intervenus et je peux donner les paroles
si le souhaitent à un opérateur par
groupe N pardonnez-moi un orateur par
groupe et un sénateur qui figure sur la
liste donc un groupe qui souhaite
prendre la parole
monsieur Lemoine
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
après avoir entendu la litanie des
orateurs qui sont succédés pour plaider
pour plaider
parce qu'il y ait beaucoup d'arguments
similaires
qui se sont succédés je me dis que
j'aimerais bien être petite souris à la
prochaine réunion du Parti socialiste
européen parce que j'irai entendu
description de l'Apocalypse
l'exploitation de l'homme par l'homme et
ce faisant vous disqualifiez aussi des
gens comme préministes Costa le
président Sanchez qui ont conduit ce
type de réforme et donc eux gouverne eux
ont été réélus eux ont assumé
et c'est je crois là une grande
différence avec effectivement votre
positionnement
Lionel Jospin est-il revenu sur la
réforme Balladur non
François
Hollande est-il revenu sur la réforme
verte non il a quelques petits
aménagements
reviendrez-vous sur l'article 7 s'il est
voté la réponse est non vous l'avez
d'ailleurs décrit comme une sorte
d'impôt sur la vie on sait bien que les
impôts vous les baissez jamais et donc
vous ne reviendrez jamais naturellement
là-dessus alors je vais paraphraser le
collègue Lucien Stanzione qui disait
ayez du courage et bien ayez du courage
retirer ses amendements de suppression
parce que vous ne reviendrez pas dessus
et donc pour le groupe RDPI en tout état
de cause nous votre compte parce que ces
grands écarts permanents non seulement
ça fait mal aux adducteurs mais ça fait
mal à la confiance dans la politique je
rappelle que nous sommes sur un débat de
clôture madame la Présidente donc j'ai
compris que vous étiez favorable à la
clôture en même temps voilà madame la
pression à vrai dire nous ne sommes pas
surpris par cette proposition de clôture
de notre discussion elle parcourt même
les couloirs du Sénat depuis quelques
heures maintenant parmi d'ailleurs
d'autres rumeurs qui circulent qui
circulent aussi
ce recours je vous le dis sincèrement ce
recours à cette procédure est un acte de
faiblesse de la part de la droite
sénatoriale c'est une marque de
fébrilité qui vous qui parcourt vos rang
comme elle parcourt les rangs du
gouvernement je au nom d'une soi-disante
obstruction que nous en petite musique
que nous entendons depuis depuis le
début depuis le début de l'examen de ce
projet de loi vous juger d'une procédure
monsieur le Président qui est peu usité
ici au Sénat
et ce à quelques heures d'une magnifique
mobilisation dans le pays et l'annonce
d'une autre grande mobilisation
samedi prochain monsieur Lemoine nous
avons du courage
mais vous vous perdez votre sang-froid
avec ce coup de force
que nous dénonçons je le dis aussi
crûment que je le pense cette procédure
est une attaque contre la démocratie et
les droits du Parlement ce n'est pas
digne du Sénat monsieur le Président
alors parce que nous avons besoin de
maîtriser parce que nous avons besoin de
maîtriser l'ordre du jour
où l'organisation des débats dans les
prochaines heures nous demandons avec
les présidents de gauche c'est à dire
moi-même le président le cadener et le
président en compta la Réunion immédiate
d'une conférence des présidents
nous poursuivons monsieur le Président
Retailleau
[Applaudissements]
pour indiquer que bien entendu de votre
ampoule la clôture puisque cela fait 5
jours et 5 nuits que nous avons à faire
à une obstruction je voudrais dire que
l'obstruction c'est la négation du rôle
du Parlement bien sûr le rôle du
Parlement c'est de débattre mais de
débattre pour voter on a été lu non pas
pour faire des groupes de parole mais
pour voter
l'obstruction c'est une sorte d'auto
effacement
d'autodésissement du Parlement vous
allez refuser puisque on va intrins
d'escargot de voir et de voter sur
l'ensemble du texte par exemple sur les
petites retraites par exemple sur
l'usure professionnelle par exemple sur
le handicap au travail et bien nous nous
voulons je crois que choisir de ne pas
voter c'est choisir de ne pas peser
méfiez-vous bien que l'obstruction ne
mène pas à commenter lentilles
parlementarisme parce que les Français
vont constater qu'à force de discuter le
Parlement ne sert à rien oui je
l'affirme je la ferme l'obstruction est
au Parlement ce qu'une désertion est un
soldat la négation même de sa mission
que le président Kader
merci monsieur le président
oserais-je dire honte à vous
honte à vous
vous êtes laissés bâillonner par le 47,1
de la Constitution et le gouvernement et
vous voulez maintenant bâillonner votre
position c'est un scandale
[Applaudissements]
l'article 38 n'a jamais été utilisé sans
faire de ma part dans cette émission
vous le faites parce que vous avez
incapable de défendre vos arguments tout
au long de ces cinq jours
nous nous sommes exprimés devant les
Français avec nos arguments avec notre
projet de société et vous vous êtes
couché
je le dis
alors mes chers collègues oui monsieur
le Président vous allez pouvoir utiliser
l'article 38 le règlement vous en donne
la possibilité
mais nous serons consultés avant cela
mais je tiens à rappeler quand même
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
du 11 juillet 2019 notez cela mes chers
amis le Conseil confirme la réserve
d'interprétation déjà formulé en 2015
selon laquelle il appartiendra au
président de séance d'appliquer cette
limitation dans le temps cette clôture
du débat ce bayonnage
cette limitation eu le temps de temps de
parole en veillant en respect des
exigences de clarté et de sincérité du
débat parlementaire
et bien nous ferons nous ferons les
recours auprès du conseil pour savoir si
cette interritée a été préservé dans
cette technique
monsieur le Président compta
merci merci monsieur le Président vous
vous rendez compte quand même de la
responsabilité que vous avez ce soir ici
oui la responsabilité un jour historique
de mobilisation vous choisissez vous
choisissez ce soir sur l'article 7 un
des articles plus importants l'article
qui va passer qui va donner deux ans de
plus aux Français de travail vous
décidez de bâillonner le Parlement vous
décidez de censurer le Sénat ce soir
vous imaginez la responsabilité que vous
avez par rapport à la population par
rapport à tous ceux qui nous regardent
c'est quand même lamentable je ne
comprends pas ça alors on nous dit alors
on nous dit on a
on a fait de l'obstruction mais on a eu
trois jours trois jours de débat on est
à l'article 7 c'est-à-dire qu'on est à
la moitié de ce texte où est
l'obstruction où est l'obstruction on a
eu des arguments un par un on les a
débattus où sont vos arguments on ne
vous a pas entendu une seule fois c'est
vous c'est avec votre obstruction
silencieuse qui donnait une image de la
politique désastreuse donc franchement
je ne comprends pas l'usage de cet
article l'usage de cet article 38 je
pense que vous avez encore la
possibilité de le retirer en tout cas je
me
avec mes deux autres collègues
évidemment on demande à ce que la
Conférence des Présidents puissent se
réunir parce que je pense qu'il y a
besoin c'est un moment grave c'est un
moment important je j'espère que vous
que vous que vous rendez compte de la
responsabilité que vous avez franchement
bien est-ce qu'il y a d'autres demandes
monsieur le Président Marseille
[Applaudissements]
non mais merci
je suis
monsieur le Président Laurent merci
merci
je vous ai écouté depuis longtemps j'ai
écouté sur tous ces banques comme tous
mes collègues vous avez utilisé les
ressources du règlement pour faire
entendre votre opposition nous l'avons
écouté avec beaucoup de patience en
étant très conciliant en étant très
conciliant vous vouliez qu'on arrive à
l'article 7 le 7
quasiment à cette heure
bon ça a été fait et on a été et ça
continue bon le règlement il est le même
pour tout le monde il est le même pour
tout le monde et nous nous utilisons
maintenant le règlement pour faire
entendre aussi une autre voix une autre
voix une autre voix je ne vous ai pas
reproché d'utiliser le règlement pour
faire entendre vos propos votre
proposition nous utilisons maintenant le
règlement
nous utilisons
et alors et alors il est il est là il y
a même d'autres articles du règlement
qui n'ont jamais été utilisés non plus
bon vous les utilisez nous les utilisons
le règlement intérieur il a été étudié
par la par le Conseil constitutionnel il
a été approuvé chacun l'utilise c'est
normal et donc à partir de maintenant et
ben
comme on dit dans les campagnes les
mouches ont changé d'âne
[Applaudissements]
d'autres demandent
d'intervention
[Applaudissements]
trois choses avant que nous procédions
votre monsieur le Président Kanner
il appartient au président de séance
d'appliquer ces limitations du temps de
parole en veillant au respect des
exigences de clarté de sincérité du
débat parlementaire et je rappelle que
les religions de notre règlement depuis
1959 ont été soumis en 2015 et 2019 au
Conseil constitutionnel comme le
président Marseille vient de le rappeler
nous avons eu sur cet article l'état 124
interventions je considère que les
exigences de clarté et de sincérité ont
été respectés par l'importance de ces
intervalles
[Applaudissements]
par ailleurs sur les sujets de rappel au
règlement puisque je voyais s'agiter
quelques petits livres verts l'article
38 prévoit strictement les modalités du
débat et je les ai respectés et le
rappel au règlement
constitue un détournement de procédure
mais qui méconnaissant s'est alinéa nous
allons donc maintenant procéder au vote
par scrutin public
la clôture qui est favorable à la
clôture le manifeste enlevant la main
avis contraire
la clôture est adoptée et nous allons
maintenant engager le vote par scrutin
public
le scrutin est ouvert
voilà de fortes tensions dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat depuis une dizaine
de minutes depuis que Bruno Retailleau
le chef de fil des LR au Sénat a demandé
l'utilisation de l'article 38 du
Règlement du Sénat alors que s'est-il
passé il y avait une longue série de
prise de parole de la gauche avec 77
amendements de suppression d'article 7
vous savez c'est un article sur les 64
ans dans la réforme des retraites et
donc le chef de fil de la droite a
demandé à ce que l'on utilise et bien un
article de règlement qui vient
contraindre les explications de vote un
pour un contre par amendement cela vient
donc réduire les temps de débat et donc
là on voit la gauche notariale qui a
dénoncé l'utilisation de cet article qui
est la première dans le débat au Sénat
depuis sa création en 2015 et donc on
voit cette forte tension avec des prises
de parole des présidents des principaux
groupes politiques du Sénat à gauche on
dénonce la mesure et à droite on la
soutient on va voir donc que cela va
tendre d'un coup les débats au autour de
cet article 7 la gauche qui demande une
suspension de séance pour la réunion de
la réunion des de la Conférence des
Présidents et donc qui pourrait
suspendre les débats on n'y est pas
encore pour l'instant on va voir donc ce
qui se passe autour de ce scrutin public
pour l'heure puisque c'est et bien ce
que tu implique se tient dans
l'hémicycle en ce moment on y reviendra
juste après avec notre jeunesse notre
journaliste Mathias s'arrez retournant
l'hémicycle pour suivre ces moments de
fortes tensions depuis une dizaine de
minutes
voilà on a entendu par exemple le
président canner dire honte à vous vous
voulez bâillonner votre opposition c'est
un scandale on a vu aussi un que il y
avait une comme ça une contestation de
l'utilisation de cet article 38 selon la
gauche cela pourrait venir interférer
avec la sincérité du débat et là-dessus
et bien ça fait réagir le président de
séance le président du sénage à un
marché qui a dit que et bien lorsque le
Sénat avait révisé son règlement en 2015
et en 2019 il l'avait fait avec et bien
l'accord du Conseil constitutionnel et
qu'il y avait eu depuis le début de
l'examen de l'article 7 c'était vers 23h
124 interventions
c'est la priorité sur ce qui se passe on
va écouter le résultat de ce scrutin
public
résultats du scrutin
344 votants 340 exprimés pour
115 contre 225 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
ses amendements de suppression
madame la Présidente vous avez souhaité
la réunion de la Conférence des
Présidents madame la Présidente vous
avez souhaité la réunion de la
Conférence des Présidents elle est
prévue demain je vous la confirme mais
si vous souhaitez ajouter à l'ordre du
jour il faut que je reçois par écrit et
je les intégrerai notre ordre du jour
sans aucun problème madame la Présidente
en application de notre règlement
j'entends bien monsieur le Président
mais pourrais-je vous demander
solennellement une suspension de séance
parce que nous avons après l'annonce du
recours à cet article 38 nous avons
besoin de nous organiser je ne vous
demande pas une heure je vous demande 15
minutes de suspension de séance attendez
j'ai la commission m'avait fait savoir
qu'elle souhaitait aussi une suspension
de séance donc la conjonction fait le
bonheur alors madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président en effet je
demande une suspension de séance de 10
minutes pour réunir la Commission et
notre commission se réunit dans sa salle
la salle 213 je vous remercie on vous
donne un quart d'heure jusqu'à ça permet
de répondre à l'ensemble des demandes à
1h30
donc
quelques minutes monsieur le Président
pour présenter cet amendement important
comme l'indique son objet cet amendement
apporte plusieurs précisions à l'article
7 il aménage la rédaction de l'article
l161-17-2 du code de la sécurité sociale
afin d'y préserver la base légale
relative à l'âge d'ouverture des droits
des assurés nés avant le premier
septembre 1961 tout en conservant bien
sûr le principe d'un relèvement
progressif de l'âge d'ouverture des
droits à 64 ans pour ceux né à compter
du 1er septembre 1961 il codifie les
dispositions relatives à la montée en
charge de l'âge de départ applicable aux
militaire qui ne justifie pas de la
durée de service exemptant de conditions
d'âge il procède à diverses
rectifications d'erreurs matériels
coordination ou clarification
rédactionnelle
il intègre l'amendement du Gouvernement
prévoyant que la mise en œuvre du
nouveau dispositif de maintien en
fonction jusqu'à l'âge de 70 ans pour
les fonctionnaires n'entraînent pas la
radiation des cadres des personnes
concernées
il précise les modalités d'entrée en
vigueur de la mesure de report de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits à 64 ans ainsi
que son application dans les
collectivités
ultramarines enfin il reprend les
demandes exprimées par plusieurs groupes
d'une clause de revoyure d'ici à 2027
il s'agit donc vous le voyez d'apporter
de nombreuses précisions que nous
jugeons
utile au sein de cet article
par ailleurs monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
du fait de sa rédaction il est de quelle
nature à clarifier les débats
en effet
en effet il va permettre au Sénat de se
prononcer d'un blog sur les paramètres
essentiels de cet article 7
dont nous avons déjà amplement débattus
depuis 19h et à vrai dire depuis le
début de nos travaux jeudi dernier
le Sénat veut-il oui ou non qu'a compté
du premier septembre 2023 l'âge
d'ouverture des droits soit
progressivement relevée jusqu'à
atteindre 64 ans pour la génération 1968
[Applaudissements]
le
Sénat veut-il oui ou non n'accélération
de la mise en œuvre de la réforme
Touraine
afin
vous allez dire oui vous afin que la
durée de cotisation requise pour
l'obtention du taux plein soit porté à
43 années à partir de la génération 1965
[Musique]
notre vote sur cet amendement permettra
à chacun de nous d'exprimer clairement
sa position et de trancher ce débat
essentiel
son adoption
ferait tomber plus de 1100 amendements
qui se répartissent
pour l'essentiel en deux catégories
premièrement
des amendements tendons à introduire des
dérogations par métier
587 amendements
n'oubliez pas n'oubliez pas dans ces
amandes blancs là de retirer celui qui
concerne les bornes d'âge de 62 à 64 ans
pour les internes en médecine
des amendements de replis des
amendements de suppression d'articles on
en a déjà eu quelques-uns me semble-t-il
tendance à supprimer des alinés à du
texte 517
mais mais je vous rassure
même après l'éventuelle adoption de
cette amendement
il nous restera vous voyez que vous avez
tout prévu il nous restera un débat
riche suscept article 7
puisqu'il centaine d'amendements de tous
les groupes politiques qui nous
permettront des débats de fonds sur des
sujets importants notamment la situation
des maires de famille la situation des
sportifs de haut niveau le rachat de
trimestres d'études supérieures et des
périodes de stage des conditions de
départ en retraite des enseignants ou
encore des sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels
la commission sera même favorable à
l'adoption de plusieurs de ses
amendements là encore venant de
différents groupes et il nous restera
évidemment un débat riche sur tous les
articles qui suivront
je vous remercie de votre attention et
vous appelez évidemment à bien vouloir
voter en faveur de cet amendement de la
commission
l'homme la présidente
[Applaudissements]
oui monsieur Assouline si vous pouvez
éviter de crier derrière ce serait ce
serait plus sympathique et surtout ça
devient fatigant en application
l'article 46 bis alinéa 2 du règlement
ce n'est pas en hurlant qu'on se fait
mieux entendre et qu'on est le plus
intelligible donc voilà
en application l'article 46 bis alien 2
du règlement la Commission a voté en ce
sens et propose au Sénat de 10 juin
l'amendement numéro
4762 de la discussion commune merci
alors
c'est bien une demande de priorité
ça voté par la Commission et je demande
en application l'article 44 alinéa 6 du
règlement la priorité d'examen et de
vote sur cet amendement
bien je suis donc saisi d'une demande de
priorité de la commission afin qu'ils
soient mis aux voix avant l'ensemble des
amendements de la discussion commune je
rappelle pour l'organisation de nos
débats c'est l'article 44 aligné à 6 de
notre règlement la priorité de droit
quand elle est demandée par la
Commission saisie au fond à moins que le
gouvernement s'y oppose le gouvernement
s'y oppose pas
merci à monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président
je note monsieur le Président mais vous
l'avez fait avant moi et avant la
suspension qu'il y a eu plus de 120
interventions sur cet article et je note
aussi pour avoir regardé rapidement
évidemment l'amendement tel que adopté
par la commission des affaires sociales
que cet amendement va permettre et va
nous permettre si les adopté bien sûr de
discuter de débattre de plusieurs
dizaines d'amendements qui pensent sur
des sujets de fonds des sujets
importants permettant de progresser sur
l'article 7 pour la disjonction la vie
du gouvernement n'est pas requis je
crois monsieur le Président et donc
évidemment le Gouvernement s'en remet la
décision du Sénat et pour ce qui
concerne la priorité traditionnellement
et par
usage mais aussi par respect des travaux
du Sénat le Gouvernement s'en remet
aussi au Sénat donc je considère que le
gouvernement de s'oppose pas la priorité
est donc de droit et
je vais maintenant vous faire demander
l'application de l'article 46 sur la
demande par la commission d'examens
séparés de l'amendement je vais
consulter là le Sénat s'il y a des
observations
madame la Présidente
oui merci monsieur le Président comme
nous nous y attendions également
voilà la réécriture de cette article 7
nous avons bien évidemment parce que
nous sommes courageux monsieur Lemoine
qui est parti
nous avons bien évidemment travaillé des
sous amendements et donc je vous remets
je remets au service de la séance les
sous amendements que mon groupe a vient
dépose pour
l'examen de cette réécriture de
l'article 7
ça veut dire que
je vais consulter néanmoins pour savoir
qui est pour
cette demande de disjonction donc ceux
qui sont pour le manifestant le vent la
main
avis contraire abstention et vous allez
pouvoir nous remettre les sous
amendements
et ce qui va m'amener madame la
Présidente à ce que la Commission se
remette au travail pour un certain temps
pour un certain temps monsieur le
Président donc je demande en effet une
suspension de séance pour venir la
commission pour examiner les quelques on
parle de 3000
combien
vous verrez le chiffre en arrivant ça se
pèse
et donc je vous propose trois quatre
heures
nous reprendrons à deux heures 45 voilà
nous avons reçu beaucoup de sous
amendements
la commission déclare y recevables
en application de l'article 44 bis
alinéa 3 du règlement les sous
amendements qui ne se rapportent pas au
texte
et qui ne s'impute pas donc correctement
et qui aurait pour effet de contredire
le sens des amendements de l'amendement
auquel il s'applique
si
si c'est très clair soit ça n'est pas
dans le texte mais un sous amendement
qui contredit le sens de l'amendement du
rapporteur n'est pas recevable
et la commission prononcerait la même
exception d'y recevabilité
à tous les amendements similaires si
nous il venait en discussion s'ajoute
270 amendements que le souple le groupe
CRCE vient de déposer la Commission n'a
pas examinée mais qu'elle considère au
regard des arguments que je viens
développer comme y recevable il reste
donc
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît non mais
on ne hurle pas
mais s'ils ont le même sens mais si on
les a vu la séance la commission je dis
à Commission des a pas examiné ils sont
dans la même mouture la même veine que
ceux qu'on a examiné c'est pas du
bricolage arrêter n'importe quoi
[Musique]
ils sont donc y recevables restent un
amendement recevable que celui du
sénateur Artano sur lequel le rapporteur
a donné envie favorable
donc en application de l'article 44 bis
aligné à neuf de notre règlement lire
recevabilité est admise deux droits et
sans débats lorsqu'il y a affirmé par la
commission au fond voilà
rappel au règlement madame rossignol
se fondera tout le monde sans doute sur
le 44 bis alinéa 3 puisque ont été
déclarés ircevables au motif que ces
amendements les sous amendements ne
s'appliqueraient pas effectivement au
texte qu'il vise l'amendement de
Monsieur Savary porte sur le même objet
que la que l'article 7 du projet de loi
premièrement deuxièmement nous avons
déposé une série d'amendements qui ont
été nous avons déposé une série
d'amendements à l'article 7 qui avait
été déclaré recevable donc ne portant
atteinte né au principe d'égalité ni
étant un contradictoire à quoi que ce
soit aujourd'hui et même les mêmes
amendements devenus sous amendements
positionné comme il le faut à La Linea 3
à 5 c'est-à-dire bien positionné et qui
était recevable hier sur le fond
deviennent irrecevables maintenant quand
ils sont sur l'amendement je ne
comprends pas pourquoi d'autant plus que
c'est une
assez extensive de la contradiction
alors qu'il ne s'agit que de dérogation
vous comprendrez bien que tout ceci doit
être clairement précisé dans le Sénat
aujourd'hui j'ai bien intégré le fait
que pour reprendre une formule célèbre
nous avons probablement juridiquement
tort parce que nous sommes politiquement
minoritaires pour autant pour autant le
Conseil constitutionnel lui n'est peu
sensible aux arguments de politiquement
majoritaire donc c'est la discussion
avec menée au fond sur ce que la
manœuvre de procédure que vous mettez en
place parce que c'est essentiel dans la
constitutionnalité de l'adoption de ce
amendement
monsieur Laurent un deuxième rappel au
règlement oui
oui un rappel au Règlement sur le même
article mais je veux insister sur ce que
vient de dire ma collègue Laurence
Rossignol comment on l'espace d'une
demi-heure
des amendements qui ont été déclarés
recevables par la commission après avoir
déclaré irrecevable je le rappelle mille
amendements donc c'est pas des
amendements que la Commission avait
oublié d'examiner puisqu'elle en a
déclaré il receva mille elle avait donc
regardé attentivement tous ceux qu'elle
avait déclaré recevable comment on
l'espace d'une demi-heure sans même
regarder ses amendements la Commission
peut maintenant nous dire qu'elle
déclare irrecevable ces amendements
donc il y a donc il y a il y a un pour
le mois un débat sur l'interprétation
qui est faite par la Commission de
l'article 44 bis alinéa 3 parce que
on nous invoque maintenant des motifs
d'irosavilité qui n'existait pas il y a
à peine une demi-heure sur des
amendements
identiques
donc il y a quand même un sérieux
problème et on ne voit pas comment ce
qui nous est présenté peut être
considéré comme acceptable en termes de
droit par le Sénat sauf à fouler au pied
toutes nos règles communes de travail
sérieux et responsable nous vous en
donnons acte je suis par ailleurs donc
je suis par ailleurs saisi par la
Commission saisie au fond d'une
exception des recevabilité c'est bien ça
à l'encontre de l'ensemble des sous
amendements déposés relatifs au
dérogations par profession et autres
types de catégories
en application s'il vous plaît du
dernier alinéa de l'article 44 bis c'est
moi qui préside
de notre règlement la question de le
recevabilité soumise avant leur
discussion à la décision du Sénat seul
l'auteur de la demande des recevabilité
et un orateur d'opinion concret la
Commission et de gouvernement peuvent
intervenir il n'y a pas d'explication de
vote la parole est donnée à la
commission madame la présidente des
affaires sociales sur cette exception du
recevabilité un orateur Dominion contrat
je vous donnerai pour un rappel
réglement monsieur le Président après
allez-y
oui je pense que vous a été distribué
non non elle n'a pas été
c'est donc une exception direcevabilité
à l'encontre je dis bien de
sous-amendement contraire au principe
constitutionnels d'égalité en ce qu'ils
instaure des dérogations par profession
pathologique catégorique il s'agit des
sous amendements qui viennent d'être
déposés voilà monsieur le Président le
sens de cette exception
alors d'opinion au contraire monsieur
Assouline
c'est là-dessus peut-être qu'il y a un
malentendu il y a ceux que vous avez
déclaré à la louche et en gros paquet il
recevable et là il y a ces amendements
précisément qui parle de rupture c'est
sous amendement qui parle
dont madame la Présidente dit que ils
sont sur les ruptures d'égalité les
mêmes amendements
n'ont pas reçu cet avis de la commission
et ont été déclarés recevables donc
cette argument de rupture d'égalité
puisque là on est sur le fond on n'est
pas sur les 1000 à la louche là et bien
sur le fond comment vous nous expliquez
que ces amendements qui étaient
recevables hier en étant examiné ne le
sont pas là est-ce qu'on peut non mais
est-ce qu'on peut avoir la réponse parce
que vous pouvez dire circuler il y a
rien à voir vous avez proposé quelque
chose de très précis
oui bien sûr ils ont jamais été déclaré
ils recevables la Commission les a
examinés et
oui ces amendements ont été examinés et
c'est le même en sous amendement ce sont
ce sont les mêmes contenus la Commission
les avait examinés et avait donné un
avis défavorable mais ils étaient
recevables pourquoi ils deviennent ils
receva maintenant on veut la réponse
alors j'ai compris que c'était une
opinion contraire à l'exception d'y
recevabilité que vous défendiez
appel au règlement monsieur Gontard
oui merci monsieur le Président rappelle
règlement sur l'article 44 bis à ina3 de
la même manière déjà moi je me pose la
première question sur le temps matériel
et la possibilité matérielle de pouvoir
étudier alors je sais pas combien il y
avait au total de sousaments qui ont été
déposés mais
je me pose quand même les questions de
cette possibilité là parce que là on est
quand même sur le fond des amendements
ça veut dire qu'il faut quand même
analyser les amendements pour savoir sur
leur recevabilité si ça correspond
justement au texte donc je mets quand
même en doute sur la possibilité
matérielle de pouvoir faire ça surtout
qu'on a déposé ses amendements on a eu
quoi 45 minutes d'interruption de séance
on les a déposés il y a quoi il y a même
pas 20 minutes je pense que voilà je me
demande comment tout ça est possible et
puis j'ai regardé on a un certain nombre
d'amendements par rapport à ce que
Madame la rapporteur a pu dire je prends
l'abonnement
4672 sur le rachat de trimestres pour
stage il me semble qu'on est tout à fait
dans quelque chose qui en tout cas qui
qui correspond tout à fait au texte qui
n'est pas en décalage par rapport au
texte donc ça me ça me pose quand même
un problème
donc voilà et puis ce qui a dit Monsieur
Assouline de la même manière donc
j'aimerais avoir des explications assez
claires parce que sinon c'est vrai qu'on
a un certain nombre de listes
d'amendements qu'on a déjà analysé et
qui me paraissent rentrer en tout cas je
vous donne ce que vous pouvez dire la
vie du gouvernement sur l'exception des
recevabilité
merci monsieur le Président le
gouvernement sur ces questions-là sont
ramener systématiquement à la vie de la
Commission et nous ont confiance aux
travaux de la commission donc favorable
alors je soumets au vote sur l'exception
d'y recevabilité
ceux qui sont favorables sur l'adoption
de manifestants le vent la main
avis contraire
adopté
nous allons donc passer
à l'examen
de l'amendement numéro 47 62 présenté
par Monsieur Savary madame Doisneau les
deux rapporteurs monsieur Savary au nom
de la commission des affaires sociales
qui ensuite d'un sous amendement qui
porte le numéro 47 63
vous l'aviez présenté monsieur Savary
vous voulez le il avait été présenté oui
il a été présenté oui tout à l'heure si
le président l'amendement a été
présenté tout à l'heure
et par contre il doit y avoir un petit
[Musique]
une rectification
qui doit être faite
concernant
concernant un dispositif
concernant un dispositif pour 5 pierres
et Miquelon pour lequel la commission
pour laquelle la Commission a demandé la
vie du gouvernement donc je demande
l'avis du Gouvernement sur cet
amendement de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
il serait peut-être bon d'entendre
monsieur Artano monsieur Artano
je suis entre vos mains Monsieur le
Président alors cette insertion de
saint-pierre-miquelon dans le texte se
pose plusieurs difficultés la première
c'est que le régime de retraite à
saint-pierre-miquelon date d'une loi du
17 juillet 87 qui n'est pas visée dont
l'amendement qui a été proposé donc il y
a un problème déjà de légistique et de
droit sur l'application du texte à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon la deuxième
chose c'est que j'ai obtenu après moult
insistance un engagement du gouvernement
et du ministère des Outre-mer de ne pas
toucher à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon pour
l'instant sur le recul de l'âge légal
pourquoi parce qu'il y a tout simplement
un dispositif de convergence au niveau
du trimestre et la durée de cotisation
pour Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et je
pense que le gouvernement veut se donner
du temps technique pour travailler avec
les opérateurs locaux et la Caisse de
Prévoyance sociale c'est la raison pour
laquelle effectivement le gouvernement
ne souhaite pas prendre cette décision
maintenant je vais à la disposition du
ministre du socle de l'engagement du
ministère des Outre-mer c'est pas une
lubie de ma part mais effectivement il a
il devrait difficultés juridiques ou de
la du fait que je ne saurais qu'invité
le ministre à ne pas persister dans ce
recul d'âge légal puisque je m'y oppose
fondamentalement mais il y a des
problèmes de droit monsieur le Président
alors monsieur le rapporteur donc je
rectifie l'abonnement conformément à ce
qui a été dit par Monsieur Artano
donc monsieur Artano retire son sous
amendement et de 47 62 devient rectifié
nous sommes d'accord la vie du
gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
simplement faire une précision pour dire
que il y a une difficulté particulière
sur Saint-Pierre Miquelon il y en a une
aussi sur Mayotte je connais
l'implication du sénateur de Mayotte qui
est juste en face de moi tany Mohamed
Sully et nous devons continuer à
travailler pour faire en sorte que les
travaux qui sont les siens puissent
déboucher et aboutir de la manière la
plus favorable pour le système de
retraite pour le reste la vie du
Gouvernement est favorable à cet
amendement rectifié
bien
alors j'ai
un sous amendement
l'amendement
toujours 47 62 pardonnez-moi qui était
présenté par Madame ponce et Monge
monsieur Montard
merci monsieur le Président non je
voulais déposer des sous amendements
nous allons procéder au vote
voilà pourquoi alors on a le droit de
déposer j'ai le droit de sous-amender un
amendement
de recevoir
première signataire madame Pau c'est
Monge qui porte le numéro 311
bien il a été distribué
et il remplace la date de 68 par la date
de 69 non il n'est pas défendu donc nous
allons procédé maintenant nous avons la
vie du gouvernement et nous allons
procéder aux explications de votre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suspends
10 minutes
ils sont tous dans la même veine de ce
qui est avant avec les mêmes les mêmes
contradictions avec le sens de
l'amendement du rapporteur donc pour les
mêmes raisons suscitent les mêmes effets
ils sont également irrecevables merci
nous passons aux explications de vote de
la parole madame la Présidente
merci Monsieur le
laissez parler la Présidente j'ai dit
quelque chose qui vous fait rire non
vous me dites
donc monsieur le Président après le
recours au 47 ans par le gouvernement
pour examiner ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificative la commission des affaires
sociales a pris la décision de rejeter
tous les sous amendements que nous avons
déposé et les a examinés à une vitesse
je dois dire et claire sans tenir compte
de ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire que des sous amendements
ont été donc rejetés alors que les
amendements les mêmes les mêmes qui les
mêmes amendements ont été retenus en
leur temps lors des travaux de la
commission des affaires
sociales donc j'ai une question moi cela
veut simplement dire que le Sénat ne
veut pas débattre de l'article 7 qui est
pourtant
le cœur du texte et le sujet le sujet
d'allongement de l'âge de départ à la
retraite qui préoccupe des millions de
nos concitoyens et de nos concitoyens
comme on l'a vu aujourd'hui dans la rue
et les jours précédent et comme on le
verra encore samedi prochain donc vous
refusez le débat démocratique et
sincèrement monsieur le Président je
pense et vous me connaissez je pense que
ça n'honore pas notre institution ça ne
mord pas le Sénat et je veux vous le dis
aussi crûment que ça nous refusons de
participer à cette entomine et nous
quittons l'hémicycle ce soir et nous
reviendrons demain
monsieur le Président Kader
que le Président je vous en êtes
monsieur le Président mais monsieur et
les ministres
vous sentez que nous sommes dans une
colère froide voilà les événements sont
passés
je regrette ce qui nous arrive
collectivement mes chers collègues je
pense que la droite sanatoriale est en
train de rentrer dans une machine
infernale qui est en train de la
submerger y compris en termes d'image il
comprend un terme d'image ce qu'a dit
notre collègue et les assassis sur l'IRO
stabilité les amendements qui n'ont même
pas été examinés
ils n'ont pas pu être examinés
techniquement mes chers amis c'est
impossible et ils ont été déclarés
irrecevables
peut-être que vous considériez que nous
n'aurions pas de riposte potentiel après
l'utilisation de
l'amendement prioritaire porté par le
rapporteur
mais nous avons le droit de nous
exprimer essayer de défendre nos idées
vous ne voulez pas manifestement et il y
a beaucoup beaucoup
d'imperfections pour ne pas dire
de bricolage dans la gestion de notre
débat de ce soir je le regrette monsieur
le Président vous n'y êtes sûrement pour
rien mais le constat il est là et les
membres de mon groupe donc ont décidé de
s'associer à la démarche qui est la
nôtre de vous laisser vous voterez
peut-être l'article 7 cette nuit et bien
nous en rendons compte devant les
Français qui ont défilé aujourd'hui mes
chers collègues nous vous laissons entre
vous
monsieur Gontard
merci monsieur le Président d'abord vous
dire quand même parce que je vois que ça
en fait rire certains parlent de cinéma
moi je trouve quand même que le moment
il est grave il est grave il est lourd
et franchement l'image je vais le dire
quand même l'image que vous donnez
on a débattu on a débattu on a des battu
longuement pendant trois jours on est
arrivé à cet article en cet article 7 il
n'y avait aucune raison d'interrompre ce
débat et de vouloir passer en force
comme le vous le faites et puis ensuite
on entrave ce soir notre droit
d'amendement parce que franchement on
dépose des sous-amendements c'est
impossible matériellement de pouvoir
faire ce que vous avez fait donc c'est
une entrave au droit d'amendement c'est
une entrave au droit parlementaire un
autre travail de parlementaire moi je
suis peiné effectivement que ça se passe
ici et que ça se passe ici au Sénat je
pense qu'on avait donné une bonne image
et que là on donne une image vous donner
une image désastreuse donc avec
l'ensemble des trois groupes
effectivement nous allons quitter
l'assemblée mais je peux vous dire que
les sénatrices et les sénateurs de nos
trois groupes ne le font pas de gaieté
de coeur franchement on avait mieux à
faire ce soir on avait mieux à faire
toute cette semaine pour contexte
effectivement d'importance un texte qui
est attendu avec des gens qui ont défilé
aujourd'hui en nombre que ça vous plaise
ou pas et que cette place au débat elle
était importante donc on va partir et on
le regrette vous ferez ce que vous
voulez cette nuit nous on reviendra
demain et j'espère qu'on pourra revenir
dans des conditions un peu plus sereine
pour pouvoir débattre et travailler
sereinement merci à tourne la Présidente
je voudrais dire quelques mots et
moi-même opposer une question monsieur
kaner vous nous dites qu'on a pas eu le
temps matériel d'examiner c'est sous
amendements nous avions pour vous tout
vous dire ce sont les amendements que le
l'amendement du rapporteur ne faite
faisait tomber ces amendements c'est
quand même 600 dérogations par métier
500 qui supprimaient des alinéas on
avait des amendements déposés sur un
article qui comprend 180 linéaires
autant que sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale tous les sous amendements que
vous mettez correspondent à vos
amendements
commandement on les a examinés on les a
tous examinés on leur a donné un avis
défavorable en commission donc quand ils
arrivent c'est pas compliqué même ce
sont les mêmes donc les mêmes qu'on a
examiné donc nous dites pas qu'on avait
pas le temps mais non nous dites pas
qu'on avait pas le temps de les examiner
ce sont les mêmes tous les mêmes sauf
quelques-uns qu'on a regrappié comme ça
et d'autres mais les autres ce sont les
mêmes donc ce sont des amendements
examinés en commission sur lequel on a
donné un avis que vous nous remettez en
sous amendement on va pas passer la nuit
après examiner des choses qu'on a
examinées donc c'est pas c'est assez
clair comme explication moi ce que je
vous dis c'est que nous la commission
elle poursuit deux objectifs c'est
contribue à la clarté des bars les
recentrant sur les enjeux du texte et
vous savez très bien et ne faites pas
les vierge et va coucher vous savez très
bien que lorsque vous déposez un millier
d'amendements plus d'un millier
d'amendements sur l'article 7 en faisant
des tas de trucs comme ça vous clarifier
et vous clarifier le débat il reste à
l'issue de l'abonnement du rapporteur
plus d'une centaine d'amendements qui
seront sur le débat de fond sur le débat
de fond et nous l'aurons demain
non je voulais vous demander si vous
mainteniez votre demande de scrutin
public sur cet amendement puisque c'est
vous qui vous aviez déposé donc je le
considère qu'il est déposé j'aurais
profité de votre présence encore avant
que vous puissiez la porte il reste 75
amendements sur cet article vous avez
dit souhaité un débat de fond demain la
commission souhaité à débat de fonds sur
cet article donc nous vous donnerons
rendez-vous pour le débat de fond sur
ces articles demain ce qui me semble et
la sagesse et la réponse du Sénat
j'allais dire amendement éclair sous
amendement et clair et je souhaite que
nous ayons un débat mais que nos
caricaturions pas l'attitude de notre
ensemble
monsieur caoutchi voulait s'exprimer
explication de vote parce que
je vais mettre on voit l'amendement
c'est pour ça
sur l'amendement et sur la réponse en
réalité je le dis pour l'ensemble de mes
collègues et peut-être pour le Conseil
constitutionnel mais le Conseil le sait
les amendements peuvent être
parfaitement déclarés recevables
lorsqu'il porte sur un article de loi
parce que et c'est la liberté des
parlementaires heureusement on a le
droit de critiquer un article de le
contredire de le modifier en revanche un
sous amendement des recevables que s'il
va dans le sens de l'amendement parce
que sinon il est en contradiction avec
l'amendement et dans ces conditions il
est irrecevable et autant les
amendements de la gauche étaient
recevables sur l'article autant ils sont
irrecevables sur un amendement
réécrivant l'article parce qu'il ne
correspondent pas au sens de l'amende
merci pour cette pédagogie en
explication de vote
je redemande le gouvernement vous savez
que nous avons rectifié l'amendement
pour intégrer Saint-Pierre et Miquelon
vous restez favorable
oui mais c'est le Président le
gouvernement reste favorable et pour
aller un peu plus loin même dans la
précision apportée au sénateur Tani
Mohamed Sully nous souhaitons qu'à
l'occasion de la poursuite du débat soit
bien précisé que ce qui sera voté ce
soir pour une application pour s'empire
et Miquelon puis cette votée dans les
mêmes termes avec les mêmes applications
mais pas les mêmes références
légistiques pour le territoire de
Mayotte
bien je vais pratiquer un scrutin public
sur cet abonnement
oui
explication de vote
une seule président j'avais demandé la
parole pour une explication de vote pour
aller dans le sens de ce que vient de
dire monsieur le ministre la réécriture
de l'article 7 à emporté les
dispositions sur Mayotte or que ce sont
des dispositions
spécifiques moi je suis favorable à cet
article 7 par contre convient de le
préciser monsieur le ministre dans le
cadre de la navette il va falloir
ajuster les dispositions sur Mayotte sur
lesquelles l'ensemble des parlementaires
de Lille les députés comme les sénateurs
nous sommes parvenus à un accord global
pour avancer
bien nous terminons sur cette tonalité
d'accord
donc je vais procéder maintenant scrutin
le scrutin est ouvert
voilà donc pour ce résumé ce condensé
les discussions autour de l'article 7 de
la réforme des retraites articles qui
prévoit le recul du départ à la retraite
à 64 ans vous l'avez vu la sénateurs ne
sont pas allés au bout de cet examen
puisque la gauche est décidé tout
simplement de quitter l'émission pour
protester contre les outils de procédure
utilisé par la droite les débats
reprendront cet après-midi il promettent
d'être très chaud on suivra ça bien
évidemment en direct sur Public Sénat
restez avec nous l'information politique
continue sur notre antenne
[Musique]